نجددت موسكو تحذيراتها من النيم جدا
اوكرانيا بالدبابات سيرفع المواجهه بين
الغربروسيا الى مستوى جديد ياتي هذا
بتزامل مع تاكيد رئيس وزراء بولندا ان
بلاده ستسلمك هذا 60 دبابه جديده بولنديه
الصنعه للمتابعه ينضم لنا الان من موسكو
مدير مكتب الجزيره زهور جورج وسوف مراسلنا
محمد المدهونه ومن كيف ايضا مراسله
الجزيره كاترين حنا اهلا بكم جميعا
اذا تصريحات القادمه من الجانب الروسي
نعم سفيان مساء الخير في البدايه بدون شك
روسيا تنظر الى ما يجري الان من محاولات
لمد اوكرانيا بمزيد من الاسلحه الهجوميه
ليس على انه حدث كارثيه بقدر ما انه ينقل
المواجهه الى مرحله جديده هذه المرحله
براي ان روسيا هو على الاقتراب بالمواجهه
بشكل مباشر بين روسيا وحلف شمال الاطلسي
وليس فقط بين روسيا واوكرانيا وان المعركه
تتجه لان تكون على الساحه الاوكرانيه بين
همم بين روسيا وبين قوات النيته فعليا
التي همم
ارسلت بدات ترسل الاستحتها النوعيه ااه
رغم ان موسكو ما تزال تكرر هذه المقوله
بان هذا المد بالدبابات مهما كان حتى وان
كان بطائرات يدل على شيئين اول شيء الاول
هو ان اوكرانيا فعليا فقدت القوه العسكريه
الرئيسيه في ما يتعلق بالمدرعات تتحدث عن
عكس اكثر من سبعه الاف مدرعه بين 4000
دبابه تم تدميرها وانا مصير هذه الدبابات
سيكون نفس مصير تلك التي حصلت عليها
اوكرانيا سابقا من دول انيتا اول لتكا
تبدا الجيش الاوكراني من الناحيه الثانيه
حتى دفع الناتو بخطوه اخرى ضد روسيا بمد
اوكرانيا بالطائرات حسب المتحدث بالنسبه
فان هذا لن يغير شيء على الارض وانما
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه ستوسع ولن
تتراجع موسكو عن تحقيقها الاهداف التي
تحدثت عنها وبالتالي ربما ركزت اليوم ايضا
حتى المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
في تصريحاتها على ان همم النيته الذي
تتدعمه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
افعليها لا يريد حلا لهذه الاذى يريد هذا
الحرب روسيا مستعده لذلك وجدد ايضا كما
ذكرنا همم الموقف الروسي الذي ياتي في
السياق ان كل ما سيصل الى اوكرانيا سيتم
تدميرا لناس الى ما قالته ماريا الزخرفه
في هذا الشعر
في العشرين من الشهر الجاري وفي قاعدتي
رمشتاين الامريكيه في المانيا عقدت الجلسه
ثامنه لمجموعه الاتصال بشان مساعده
العسكريه لاوكرانيا نتائج هذا الاجتماع
تشهد على عدم تحلي الغرب بالمسؤوليه
اطلاقا ورغبتهم في تصعيد الصراع اكد الدول
الناتو انها ستزيد امداد اكياس بالاسلحه
الهجوميه الثقيله الحديثه اؤكد ان اي سلاح
غربي ينتهي به المطاف فيه اوكرانيا
سيصبحوا هدفا مشروعا لقواتنا الامدادات
بالدبابات لن تغير الوضع لصالح نظام كيف
لكنها تذهب بالدول الغربيه الى مستوى جديد
من المواجهه معاملتنا
عن اعلان بولندا
والرسائل من خلال هذا الاعلام
نعم سفيان رئيس الوزراء البولندي مرتاح
وسعيد للقرارات الاخيره المتخذه في
العواصم الغربيه تحديدا في برلين واشنطن
بارسال دبابات قتاليه لكيف وبولندا هي في
صداره الداعمين العسكريين لاوكرانيا هذا
ما تريد بولندا قوله من خلال اعلانها
وتعهدها بارسال 60 دبابه اضافيه 30 منها
من نوع بي تي 91 هذه الدبابات المطوره عند
الدبابات في 72 الدبابات من الحقب
السوفياتيه التي ارسلت بالفعل 250 دبابه
منها قبل سته اشهر كما قال رئيس الوزراء
البولندي فضلا عن اربع 10 دبابه من نوع
لبرد اثنان المانيه الصنع التي كانت
بولندا تعهدت بارسالها بغض النظر عن
الموافقه الالمانيه وكانت هناك الكثير من
الانتقادات واللهجه الحاده التي استخدمها
رئيس الوزاره البولنديه خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه والاسابيع الماضيه حقيقه
قبل ان تعلن المانيا اخيرا عن موافقتها
على ارسال هذه الدبابات سترسل هي بنفسها
هذه الدبابات وستسمح باعاده تصديرها من
قبل دول اخرى وهو امر يقول رئيس الوزراء
الهولندي انه كان من المحرمات قبل اشهر
قليله فقط قبل عام لم يكن متخيلا ان ترسل
اوروبا والولايات المتحده فخر مجنزراتها
افضل دباباتها لاوكرانيا لكنه ينسب الفضل
في ذلك الى البساله وشجاعه والقوه التي
اظهرها الجنود الاوكرانيون في التصدي
للعدوان الروسي كما يسميه ويصفه ويذكر
دائما بان اوكرانيا ليست سوى خطوه الاولى
على طريق العدوان الروسي وستكون هناك دول
اخرى اذا لم تتحلى الدول الغربيه الولايات
المتحده ودول حلف شمال الاطلسي جميعها
بالشجاعه
والجراه كما قال وتحدث عن ان الخوف هو
سلاح روسيا اي سي وليس الدبابات او السلاح
النووي او الطائرات الخوف الذي تنشره بين
الحلفاء والشركاء الغربيين هو هذا السلاح
الرئيسي الذي تستخدمه موسكو وستكون هناك
نبوءه ذاتيه التحقق بين الحلفاء الغربيين
اذا ما صدقوا هذا الكلام وان التضامن مع
اوكرانيا هو السلاح الذي يجب ان يجابه به
هذا العدوان الروسي لذلك فان همم بولندا
ماضيه في دعمها العسكري تطالب بالمزيد
تطالب بتغيير الذهنيه التي يتعامل بها
الغرب مع الحرب ويقول حتى رئيس الوزاره
الهولندي بان بلاده ستكون همم في صالح
تزويد اوكرانيا بطائره مقاتله اذا ما طرح
هذا الموضوع ولكن القرار يجب ان يكون
جماعيا بين حلف شمال الاطلسي كما قال
زينسكي كان قد رحب بالدعم بولندي هذا
كاترين ماذا في تفاصيل الموقف
صحيح سفيان ومنذ اعلان القررين الامريكي
والالماني بتزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات الثقيله والمتطوره
ينصبوا الجهد الاوكراني هنا بشكل اساسي
على مسالتين اولا توسيعه ما تسميه
اوكرانيا حلفه الدبابات
والثانيه مساله التسريع في التدريب
والنقطه الثانيه هي موضوع الذهاب نحو
انواع اخرى من الاسلحه الهجوميه وهي ما
بدات تطالب به اوكرانيا بتزويدها بصواريخ
بعيده المدى وكذلك بمقاتلات من طراز اف 16
فيما يتعلق بالمساله الاولى توسيع وحلف
الدبابات تعمل اوكران يا حاليا على توسيع
هذا الحلف الذي تقول انه مكون حاليا من
اثنتين 10 دوله وهي تطمح لان تحصل من خلال
هذا الحلف على ما يقارب 350 الى 400 دبابه
اليوم تحدثت السلطات عن قرار بولندا همم
واربعه 10 اخرى من نوع لابرد اثنين اضافه
الى ما اعلنت وكندا بالامس عن تزويدها
اوكرانيا اربع دبابات من نوع لابرد وايضا
همم
تجري حوله مفاوضات مع الفرنسيين حول
دبابات لاكليرك الفرنسيه بحيث كانت بالامس
وزيره خارجيه فرنسا في همم اوكرانيا
تحديدا في اوداسه وتحدثت عن ان فرنسا سوف
تعطي قريبا جدا قرارها بشان اعطاء
اوكرانيا هذه الدبابات وهي تستكشف امكانيه
المساعده بهذا الخصوص اضافه الى ما قالته
ايضا وزاره الدفاع عن الاوكرانيه اليوم عن
المساعدات البريطانيه في هذا الاطار وهي
تحدثت عن 200 مركبه المدرعه قدمتها
بريطانيا لاوكرانيا اذا هذا على صعيد حلف
الدبابات صوفيا اما على الصعيد الاخر
المساله الاخرى التي بدات تبرز بقوه في
اوكرانيا في كل تصريحات المسؤولين هنا وهي
ضروره تزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ بعيده المدى
وكذلك بمقاتلات
16 اليوم سكرتير مجلس الامن القومي نشر
على حسابه على تويتر همم ما قال فيه ان اا
طائرات مقاتلات اف 16 قريبا في اوكرانيا
هذا ما كان قد طلب به ايضا الرئيس سيلنسكي
خلال اجتماع رمشتاين الاخير طلب بان يكون
هذا الامر موضعا مباحثات اجتماع رمش عين
المقبل في ذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا وهذا ما بحثته ايضا قائد القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه بالامس مع رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه بشان التزويد
اوكرانيا بنماذج جديده من الاسلحه
المتطاوله في اقرب وقت ممكن بشكل تسمح
لاوكرانيا بان تغير في همم معادلات الحرب
وانت تتمكن من استهداف مواقع جديده
ومستودعات القوات الروسيه لا يمكنها
استهدافها بدون هذه الاسلحه المتطاوره
صوفيا
الذي كان معنا من مصر